yeah welcome to this video about round
three of the bill Grandmaster tournament
who built Switzerland yeah sad news
today m it is at Alexander morose avicii
to withdraw from the tournament and due
to some health issues I'm there are no
details posted so i don't know more than
than you do probably if you read it
already so I'm he's unable to complete
this tournament he lost the first two
games as maybe also explains his
somewhat yeah we had performance in
those two games and if he wasn't in good
health so this maybe explains why he was
sort of yeah out of salt in those games
so he'll he'll leave from home or maybe
already left home to get proper
treatment and yeah he's actually
replaced by am by another player this is
victor bulu gone from Moldavia his lots
of very strong run master 2700 something
rated and he will join the tournament
here starting tomorrow even so he's
there on very short notice young and I
think he'll also give us some
interesting chess to watch alright
today's game so I'm Carlson didn't play
today he had this game scheduled with
Moreau switch so this wasn't played but
we had 22 interesting games coming up
anyway and this was a first one was
unleash curry with white against it yen
macro and micro was brought brave enough
to play the Kings Indian again which he
already did against wang hao and lost
and yeah he lost again due to some it
looked to me a very deep preparation and
super complicated game um the other game
which i'm going to show you is one
how China's number one against us number
one player Hikaru Nakamura and this was
yeah well a sharper than sharp game so
let's get going here one plate form he
plays both afford d4 so hard to prepare
and nakamura goes straight for the
Sicilian night off he plays all kinds of
openings of course but the night of his
son yeah a constant guest in his games
he plays it rather often and also Fitz's
uncompromising style one how goes for
Bishop g5 the old main line the may be
the sharpest move e six now and f form
yeah here wide after f4 has to reckon
with various black smooth black hand
play em yeah basically everything as we
tried him from Bishop e7 to Quincy 72
nite bd7 of course the notorious Queen B
6 move the poisoned pawn variation
fissures and also kasparov's favorite
line which can be too hair-raising stuff
here with white giving up this pawn on
the queenside but like yeah being very
much underdeveloped so all kinds of
hooves possible here and another move
which is actually very rarely plate is
the one that Hikaru here chooses he
plays b5 and this is some the so-called
polygon FC variation developed by back
then soviet grandmaster left Beluga yes
key he invested back in the day we are
talking about 1970s year he invested
maybe weeks a month to analyze this line
here he even wrote a book about it this
whole procedure in analyzing this very
fascinating line and he played it with
quite some success in the 70s and 80s on
nowadays it's considered to be rather
risky but this is basically all I know I
never considered playing this with with
either color so I don't know the details
well be five obviously is the move that
yeah black wants to play because um he's
got this this idea over before
undermining the e4 pawn so this is
simply the most aggressive move you can
play but it has got one one drawback and
this is what what's played in the game
of course the movie 5 first then you
might think okay black it's just just
losing a piece here with this pin but
like has a tricky a can take and now the
move Queen c7 this is quite funny Queen
text d5 pawn and now I'm yeah white has
I think some some other options but the
main move here were forced to capture on
f6 I think tal once you've tried to
second be five against poor guy have ski
okay he takes f6 like Jesus check and
this way get the bishop back white
interposes here with his Bishop and
black get some Bishop back so we have a
really yeah unique position where ya
black has only the Queen developed and
he's wide-open on the on the queenside
he has got this to those two ball moves
in but his has got nothing developed
here this this kind of stuff can be an
issue and likes king is selling the
center so this whole line is obviously
very risky white has got three pieces
out already and yeah what what's what's
the point here for black why do I go for
this well black has two bishops which is
some put yourselves
to do that I want to do that like has
the two bishops and the potentially very
strong bishop this dark squared bishop
on f8 is unopposed why does some wood
week on the dark squares so in the long
term if black doesn't get mated he will
have a very good position but
unfortunately he yea rather often gets
made it in this line okay a lot not
theoretical expert and I don't have the
time to invest like ours to to get a
picture of this so I'll go to the to the
main num points of this game happening
later wider castles here he's got
alternatives but ok castles and now the
somewhat extreme again looking rook a
seven which is actually not so uncommon
and in this kind of Sicilian positions
black tries to immediately get the rook
to e7 and utilizing here this d file so
why does nicely develop but he's got
loose pieces this deformed night is
somewhat somewhat loose in the sentence
and not supported by opponent can be
pinned with the rocker maybe even Bishop
c5 so black really quickly tries to use
this aspect of the position but he's not
actually nearing with proper development
so weiter goes Queen d3 now preparing
group 81 and also protecting the C 3
square where maybe blacks Queen was
intending to get a check in like goes
rook t7 as promised and now sets up this
simple threat so white needs to react he
threatens to take and play Bishop c5 so
wyd would would play a move like this
here then black and grab this and win
the queen of the game so what needs to
attend to this threat and he goes 94
certainly a yeah understandable move
using a tempo on the Queen
and getting rid of this threat Queenie 5
and now the tricky move Knight f3 he
retreats from this this pin and attacks
the Queen yeah the Queen really needs to
go here what what um yeah what squared
to choose he's chewed some Quincy 7 in
fact um here instead of Quincy 7 I'm of
course one alternative was to simply
grab also this pawn but this really
looks super risky to grab you even more
material I don't think that's an
apparent refutation maybe but very risky
okay Quincy 7s sort of logical to get
this all coordinated white that needs to
move his Queen it was attacked by the
rook so the sidestep and black now
Bishop e7 finally developing a minor
piece and 95 yay around here I think
we're maybe on new territory at least I
didn't find any games in my database
which it's not the biggest one around
but it doesn't seem like it's a it's a
super popular position let's let's put
it that way 95 yeah obviously intending
to do something on those sensitive
squares also maybe a long attacking
moves on e6 and f7 so these are whites
mean attacking points is six and f7
black plays h6 attacking this night and
immediately try to clarify the situation
here and now I won how plate Queen age
three using this the spin of the pawn to
protect the night he had alternatives um
one interesting one was actually
immediately sacrificing on f7 white
could do that um possible lines
ah let's say black captures with the
rook then why it has got this this
possible team pinning this piece and now
like I think only has got one possible
defense just because why does also
threatening to take on g7 and getting
the rook into play and win everything
back with interest so black needs to
play g6 here there's no other move right
takes and rook g8 winning a tempo here
on the bishop and then possible
continuation could be take here King
takes Queenie to rock g6 something like
this and very likely that black is fine
here he's got the the rookie on a nice
position and maybe has got ideas to to
get his pieces and do a good good spots
iam I don't think neither seven is so
great I'm an alternative would be king
f7 it's also playable this can lead to
an immediate draw let's say I need to do
this in some other way here just a
second king of seven and here white
could could play 95 takes and just this
one also with check King takes crucial
five and this will end in a casual check
which black cannot avoid it's just um
just a drawing all right so this was an
alternative but like at least had the
possibility to to get this I stepped
back to too many moves I was talking
about 97 here this is at least the draw
for black so y divided this Queen age
three and now g6 plate suddenly an
understandable move trying to keep this
close to yonder on the kingside Bishop
d3 also
yeah I moved its that's understandable
getting on those sensitive squares also
protecting the night 96 catching up in
development until white played King
edgemont the other sort of ever useful
move here with the f porn um yeah having
been moved this king movers really
something you have to do very often once
he had alternatives he could of course
think of um sacrificing here and this
leads to a complete mess I think so 90
of seven of course the move that you you
can consider what could happen if black
takes with a king then white throws
another check and another piece here
Queen h8 that now just a cool move 95
with the idea to to get rid of this
bishop and yeah this is very very hard
to to analyze just the possible line
let's a rupee one possibly intending to
to to him to take this wish this night
something like this could happen black
setting up a counter thread check go in
here check takes on g6 came here 25 yeah
and it's a complete mess don't know
what's happening here first instinct is
that black may be okay with this this
potentially very strong Bishop pointing
pointing here on the King side but the f
porn isn't bad either so completely
unclear on either 70 black doesn't need
to take with the king he can also
consider taking with the rook can we
check
King the aid and okay of course this
looks really hairy yeah difficult for
foot black to play and then a cool move
like rook 81 just intending those
discovered checks and well it looks a
really really dangerous rock t77 i think
is the only move even and this could
continue along these lines f7 with a
simple but very very mighty threat
Queenie 5 to cover the eighth square and
then possible line would be taking on g6
king c7 and well you can really continue
from here it's a complete mess let's say
nine f6b should be six and then white
could even take on d7 allowing those
those checks here and the computer
actually tells me it's a draw a
repetition everything else would lose so
I'm in a practical game between human
players Sam it's an absolutely murderous
position to play this hole opening
choice for four blankets of course super
risky sort of really put your hand into
the lion's mouth and hope that it
doesn't bite I'm not saying black is
worse I mean maybe black is perfectly
fine it's just yeah dancing on a
tightrope okay so what actually happened
here he didn't take on f7 he played King
edge 1 preparing all this and black
responded 95 the checking this this
Bishop possibly taking it but also
covering an already six but g6g 6 + f7
like covers those Center sensitive
squares and white um puts all his pieces
into a factor of a one Bishop
for ya attacking the rook here on new
one put move 33 so staying on the undie
file and now Bishop b5 also a move to
protect e6 so it's a nice defensive move
and why decides on the regrouping here
played special be to possibly attending
to reroute the speech to to g4 and then
sacrificing only six yeah here black gum
played 90 SI form an alternative which
the computer absolutely loves her black
this to to grab another porn but I think
he just rejected this because it's very
dangerous to to grab another porn maybe
this is the best move but I mean for you
will player with 25 minutes on the clock
a very tough decision on just a simple
line a three-year maybe night see for
Bishop takes Bishop takes yeah group g1
and this for example looks absolutely a
good for black it's not super clear but
something a lot something like this here
this is not entirely clear if like is
really winning here he's got two weeks
two pawns but White's the last some
initiative but I think he would have
chosen this um I think he will dislike
something else about the porn wrap um
all he didn't he didn't grab the porn he
played nazi for which looks very logical
also activating the snide rook t3 and
Queenie five activating the Queen so I
think by now we can say that black
should be okay here he's got all his
pieces out except for the rukon age 8
and the king is only eight
but he's got the two bishops very nice
Bishop on d5 good night on c4 and you
really don't see at the moment that why
should have something decisive here
still it's uh of course very difficult
to play this position why 20mg for now
yeah and this is the critical position
here here nakamura played I think maybe
already yeah losing move from a good
position to a very bad position in one
move this is just typical of those ultra
sharp line cm what he played is he
played 92 2d6 but let me show some
alternatives and what would happen if if
black takes only for this is something
you need to consider possibly why just
recaptures here and if black now would
take on e4 then white has this this cute
idea I'm not sure this is so great for
black it's not entirely clear but maybe
he's got something better one
alternative actually want some too yet
to be greedy and just grab even another
pawn and it's not clear if white has got
anything decisive at least them the
computer doesn't find anything after
like two minutes or something it doesn't
seem to have an easy solution I mean all
kinds of pieces are hanging from white
and it's not apparent that he can
sacrifice maybe he can just grab it it's
very difficult to tell what he did
looked very natural really but it hasn't
has huge drawback he played them disqus
a 96 move and now why'd ya can can
really break through here rook takes d5
this is very strong
the simple point being um if black would
check with the pawn you just grab the
end yeah just win the game being lots of
material up so black guy needs to take
with the Queen and now it continues the
next blow here Bishop takes e6 yeah
again Black has no choice he needs to
grab this as also the Queen was hanging
a requesting you need to take and now
the strong follow-up f7 check yeah and
now black is really in a huge trouble
what should he do let's start with the
easy ones if you would take with the
night one has this check here winning
the Queen so he cannot take with this
piece um in the game he played the King
dat but Luke f7 was an idea then white
grabs here Queen takes Knight f7 and at
first you think black and resigned but
he actually has the funny move castles
using using this this position on the FL
so if white would grab the Queen its
rook f1 checkmate um so castles oops no
hassle see and what what white can do is
he can just play Queen here Queenie
seven and now shred everything off to
into winning end game with an extra porn
and the better pawn structure white is
winning quite quite easily here so this
was rook takes f7 kingly seven as
another move
and this is really a this is really a
nice now maybe this is what what
Nakamura overlooked I don't know Queen
age six it's not so difficult but it's a
very very cute move if black would take
now on on h6 chutney it's made very nice
so black cannot cannot grab the Queen so
what should he do the only move really
is rook back covering f8 the f8 square
but this doesn't really help what can
just promote him and give a check here
this is all forced so and here watchin
again try it down to an end game this is
not so clear-cut compared to the other
end game which is quite similar but
they're black had far worse King
position so why it should be close to
winning sorry close to winning here with
the extra porn blacks activity shouldn't
shouldn't be enough him so on f7 he went
King d8 yeah now what just grabbed c6
with check King move and some promotion
so wyd managed with this yeah rook
sacrifice at the end to promote the pawn
and get back clock his material and yeah
now he needs to even play this somewhat
poor looking on Bishop da move he
couldn't play the King move because of
super huge for Kia 27 also on the cards
so black just loses everything here he
cannot move the King so he needs to play
this the self pin and here um yeah why
just needs to be careful a bit because
black has the counter made threat yandi
one
white captured on d6 and here black
played the funny move King bee aid he
could he could have cost take on d6 with
the Queen but this should this kind of
stuff all only moose needs to winning
king and porn and game with just the
extra deep on which ones easily yeah
like blech blech is just losing him this
96 move simply I think gave the game
away from a very good position to ya to
almost lost position so he played this
funny King move because they're still
dismayed threat so white needs to attend
this and the only real possibility is
due to get the route back and now black
takes Janna white plays it simple he
just takes the bishop on d8 like okay a
little bit a little teasing mafia
threatening Queen f1 check made white
attends to this and no black must
recapture yeah no I just grabbed this
pawn on g6 and his two pawns up for the
good and black still has a bad King
position so this should be winning we
can look at the rest of this why just
check yeah kept the positive sides about
his position two weeks two pawns I try
to attack here but King yeah black has
got a little bit of activity but you
simply ya cannot force any serious
concessions for white you just need to
regroup a bit here h3 gives a little bit
of room for the king and white can try
to improve his position with something
like let's say rook see one and then
Queen t1 and then trying to activate
here on CND file I think white is really
winning what Cairo played an outlet
Queen g3 this of course makes it a bit
easier
it was lost anyway why just now place
queen h2 and using the spin gets rid of
the Queens and this is really a
reasonable and yoke a week I resigned
here with like he's got no alternative
to today allowing a queen exchange and
then those two points in the rook
endgame just decide the day yeah a very
sharp game I mean really this this whole
line was telling telling the white
player okay we don't draw today we play
a really yeah sort of a fistfight kind
of chess game and it seems that Hikaru
letters covered down for just one moment
which Wang Hao really took advantage of
with this rook t5 move so at this
position here Queen oops this move here
nie to nie 26 really a was what was the
big deal 96 Andrew t5 this decided the
game yeah so um let's have a quick look
at the standings it's a bit butchered up
of course because Magnus only has two
games played but while the tournament
leader has Harnish Giri with two wins
and draw very good performance up to now
but one how also has got two wins he won
the first round against back row and now
this game against a camera Janna camron
minus one he lost one game and drew two
games with very fun very interesting
fighting chess but didn't pay off yet um
and okay then we have got back row 11
nice game against morose which but lost
to so it's a very very fighting
tournament got far more decisive games
up to now then draw so nice and nice
stuff alright thanks for watching hope
you enjoyed the game if you're a fan of
your car or you yeah you might not be
too too thrilled to see this but you
got all chances to to come back with his
with this kind of Starla can always
starter yeah seriously wins as well yeah
thanks for watching and I'll cover more
games from bill soon